In this lecture, we introduce
Markov chains, a general class
of random processes
with many applications
dealing with the evolution
of dynamical systems.
As opposed to the
Bernoulli and Poisson
processes, which are
memoryless in a sense
that the future does
not depend on the past,
Markov chains are more
elaborate, as they
allow some dependencies
between different times.
However, these dependencies
are of simple and restricted
nature, captured by the
so-called Markov property.
Conditional on the current state
of the Markov chain, its future
and past evolutions
are independent.
As mentioned in
the unit overview,
we will only consider
discrete time
Markov chains that evolve
within finite state spaces.
This allows us to concentrate
on the main concepts
without having to deal with
some required technical details
needed to study general Markov
processes under continuous time
and general, possibly
uncountable, state spaces.
We will first introduced
the basic concepts,
using the simple example
of a checkout counter
at a supermarket, an example
of a simple queuing system.
We will then abstract
from the example
and give some general
definitions, including
the central notions of states,
transition probabilities,
Markov property, and
transition probability graphs.
Afterwards, we will look
at various questions,
such as predicting what
will happen in n-steps
in the future, given the
current state of our system.
We will define n-step
transition probabilities exactly
and show how to calculate
them efficiency.
We will also discuss
what could happen
when we let the Markov chain
run for a very long time.
We will end this
lecture by introducing
the notions of recurrent
and transient states
and their importance in studying
Markov chains in the long run.